regardez son la mer s'il est là les
chérit tant dans sa vie si on fait la
cuisse alors comment ça va bien merci
il y perd 6 d'or s'annonce serrée mais
aussi des bourses
comment ça va mais sheridan toute
l'équipe de top gear est avec nous ce
soir
franchement je les kiffe et vous
cartonnez vous méritez pas ce que vous
avez amené un vent de fraîcheur votre
trou c'est ce que je lui dis à chaque
fois en animation hochtief c'est nous
aussi
ils disent qu'ils pensent voilà donc
bras fait signe à ses membres à main
vous faites qui fait vraiment je
remercie tous ses missions chez les
missions que je que je kiffe
j'ai une équipe de top gear solid ou en
guilde vous donc ses gains alors il ya
une personne ici qui ne sait pas ce
qu'elle fait là elle a essayé tout à la
non c'est vrai elle a essayé alors les
cherry qui veut faire une course contre
isabelle paganon agathe et agathe
justement de t'habiller juste pour faire
la paix avec israël
aussi si je te fais un accident non mais
tu peux pas me faire d'accidents voyages
payés parce que attention c'est parti
nous voulons beaucoup d'attention ces
faits là alors il a merdé suffisent à
peine les bras ballants douche
isabelle va voir elle va voir quand même
quelques conseils si je l'entraînais
conseil attention 3 2
[Musique]
jour et le tricheur à cadeau royal
c
mais pas moi
et je m'arrête non
en effet barré
ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
le gentleman mer des semis les pas quoi
ça s'est arrêté et ça suffit n'importe
quoi cette séquence à un moteur qui sont
fait la belle avec mathias ont déconné
où est ce que vous pouvez pas nous faire
une démonstration de médoc pascale et
les il est vraiment ce que c'est et
professionnels bruce et yann adhésif est
tout un truc et ocde oecd passé
maintenant on commence pas à temps ok
c'est parti gilles benoist
ces sonos et la tricherie l'affiché dans
des petits sacs quelque chose dans la
convention teulière la triche est
autorisée non c'est vrai mais bien sûr
que non elle est repartie il est reparti
roda c'est toujours comme ça avec les
faits toujours tout foirer n'abaissez
pas possible sans rigoler mais pavlovien
robert va faire une belle course trop
bien j'ai dit non non les ché est ce
qu'on peut voir maxime galy sinon maxime
gagné la maxime qui dit tiens si mme
kenny mais lui le tanit
je vous libère un peu le à la tension
avant la neige 3 2
c'est pas juste une liste bien
pour désolé j'ai chéri senna n'importe
quoi allécher